democratic congress people seek to purge
media outlets they don't like and
president biden holds a commemorative
event for the 500 000 americans who have
died of covet i'm ben shapiro this is
the ben shapiro show
the ben shapiro show is sponsored by
expressvpn your data is your business
protected at expressvpn.com
we'll get to all the news in just one
moment first a reminder you're spending
way too much money on that cell phone
bill like
hundreds of dollars a year too much
money on that cell phone bill well this
is why you should check out my friends
over at puretalk usa over a thousand of
you
have already done so you've made the
switch from your overpriced wireless
carrier to pure talk over the past
couple of months
what are the rest of you waiting for if
you're with att verizon t-mobile your
family could save over
a year just by switching to puretalk you
get the same great coverage because they
use the exact same towers as one of the
big carriers
you can even keep your phone and your
number but you will save a fortune
by the way puretalk is the top rated
wireless company by consumer affairs
they've got the absolute best customer
service team based right here in the
united states
if that sounds good it gets even better
because right now you can get unlimited
talk text and six gigs of data for just
30 bucks a month
and you're saying to yourself okay what
if i use more than six gigs of data well
here's the thing if you go over on data
they're not going to charge you for it
grab your mobile phone dial pound 250
say ben shapiro
to get started when you do you'll save
50 off your first month
dial pound 250 say ben shapiro that's
the key word to get started pure talk
usa is simply smarter wireless save time
save money check out puretalk usa today
dial pound 250 and say
keyword ben shapiro for 50 off your very
first
month okay so it is kind of fascinating
that in america's narrative discourse
there's a
a lie that is told it goes something
like this the great threat to american
democracy lies on the authoritarian
right
the authoritarian right is the biggest
threat to american democracy this is
something that you hear very often in
the media you hear it a lot from
democratic congress people
and they like to use their example what
happened on january 6th now january 6th
was an act of criminality it was an
act of evil and there was something
authoritarian to people attempting
to stop the democratic processes from
taking place and going forward
and working for sure you don't have to
deny the presence of an authoritarian
right to also recognize that the centers
of power
in american life the centers of
institutional power in american life
do not lie with the authoritarian right
they lie with the authoritarian left now
it is worthwhile at this point
to define our terms so the uh
the very term authoritarianism is very
often used kind of vaguely
what exactly does it mean to be
authoritarian people use it
simultaneously to mean fascist and
totalitarian
authoritarian has a little bit more of a
specific definition
typically when you are talking about the
characteristics
of authoritarianism so let's talk about
that for a second
so there have been a bunch of studies on
what authoritarianism actually looks
like what does it mean to be
authoritarian so there's a guy named
theodor adorno and he very
early in 1950 wrote a book he was a
frankfurt school member he's a
marxist theorist and he wrote a book
about authoritarianism and his basic
suggestion is that authoritarianism was
a naturally right-wing phenomenon
he's a marxist of course he thought that
anybody who disagreed with him
was sort of an authoritarian his idea is
that america was right for the plucking
america was about to fall into
authoritarianism because america wasn't
left-wing enough
because he wrote this very famous book
called the authoritarian personality
in which essentially he suggested that
anti-semitism and authoritarianism
were outgrowths of a particular mindset
that also sprang from capitalism
now this was untrue but it did lead to a
lot of study as to what an authoritarian
personality
would look like and there was a harvard
social scientist named robert altmeier
he created a right-wing authoritarianism
scale
he was attempting to detect three
particular character traits these were
character traits of the authoritarians
character trait number one of an
authoritarian was authoritarian
submission
willingness to submit to established and
legitimate authorities right you're
willing to
to just go along with whatever the boss
says two authoritarian aggression
right you're going to perform aggressive
act on behalf of the authoritarian
and three conventionalism right you are
going to abide by all of the approved
social conventions this was right-wing
authoritarianism and for a long time
social scientists
who tend to be very left-wing thought
there was no such thing as left-wing
authoritarianism
left-wing authoritarianism just did not
exist because left-wingers were
progressive
and wonderful and anti-violence and
pacifistic okay well it is very clear at
this point there is left-wing
authoritarianism and in fact social
scientists
have found that left-wing
authoritarianism
is quite common when university of
montana social psychologist lucian
conway
created a scale to mirror altimeier's
scale
what he found is that the highest score
for authoritarianism was for liberals
and liberals had the highest score for
authoritarianism and he described
authoritarianism this way
right here's here's what they said these
particular social scientists from
university of montana
about what left-wing authoritarianism
looked like left-wing authoritarianism
if right-wing authoritarianism was about
submission
and aggression approved by the bosses
and conventionalism a belief
that your traditional morality is the
only approved social convention and that
you get to shut down everything else
then left-wing authoritarianism is sort
of the mirror image left-wing
authoritarianism believes and
revolutionary aggression
that the system has to be torn down the
hierarchy of power has to be destroyed
top-down censorship they simultaneously
believe in in order to achieve utopia
you have to shut everybody else up
and finally anti-conventionalism which
these social scientists described as
quote
reflecting a moral absolutism concerning
progressive values
and concomitant dismissals of
conservatives as inherently immoral
an intolerant desire for coercively
imposing left-wing beliefs and values on
others and a need for social and
ideological homogeneity in one's
environment in other words
they're going to cram down a particular
moral worldview that says that you are
evil because you disagree so those are
the three characteristics of left-wing
authoritarianism
revolutionary aggression and approval
for it which you saw over the summer
when virtually the entire left wing
winked and nodded at the most damaging
riots in american history
top-down censorship directed at group
authority
right the group authority as a means of
regulating right-wing beliefs and
behaviors we have to have
the bosses shut everybody else up right
this is the diversity training you see
inside your corporations or as we will
see
democrats in congress trying to shut
down free speech and
anti-conventionalism a belief
that everybody who disagrees with you is
inherently a moral lesser
person a morally lesser person a bad
person these characteristics
are these characteristics of left-wing
authoritarianism are extraordinarily
common
not only are they common they are
dominant in our institutional culture
dominant and you see it every single day
those particular factors
you see it at work every single day so
when people say you know right-wing
authoritarianism is dominant
again you don't have to deny the
president of right-wing authoritarianism
to recognize that the institutional
power in our country
is dominated by authoritarian leftists
who seek top-down censorship
who believe that their progressive
worldview is the only worldview that
matters
and who believe in a revolutionary
aggression designed at tearing down the
quote-unquote hierarchies of power
that describes to a t what so many
members of the democratic party are
doing today
the reason i bring this up is because
two members of congress
have now issued a series of letters to a
variety of
of platforms and common carriers
designed to shut down dissent one member
of congress is named anna eschew
the other is named jerry mcnerney they
issued this letter and this is just
full authoritarian stuff we have a first
amendment for a reason
it says congress shall make no law
congress shall make
no law abridging freedom of speech so
what have our members of congress
decided to do
instead of making a law they're going to
essentially
create agents in the private sphere to
do their bidding they know they can't
pass a law that bridges freedom of
speech or it'll get struck down by the
supreme court
instead what they do is they say we will
punish you if you do not do the
censorship we wish you to do in the
private sphere
this is the new model not top-down
censorship
just from government but top-down
censorship with government actors
using as a cudgel their power in order
to beat
corporations into submission and force
those corporations to adopt
the precept of the authoritarian left
and to censor from the top
we'll get to what i mean by this in just
one second because we really are living
in an authoritarian time
this is an authoritarian moment that we
are watching unfold before us
right now and it is deep and it is
threatening and it has been creeping an
american life
and unfortunately the authoritarianism
of the left
was fostered in general and in very
strong ways
by the reactions of things like january
6th it was an opportunity for the
authoritarian left
to get the upper hand in american
discourse because free speech is now bad
free exchange of ideas is now bad it
could be incitement if you say something
they don't like it could be dangerous
and so now is a great time to shut down
free speech to shut down individual
rights and to use all powers
that they have at their disposal in
order to do so i'll explain in just one
second because
again the fact that this is is happening
in the united states
should scare the living hell out of
everybody who believes in individual
rights right left or center
i'm not saying everybody on the left is
a member of the authoritarian left i'm
saying there is an authoritarian left
and it is becoming the dominant mode in
the democratic party and that's a very
frightening thing
get some more of it in one second first
let us talk about the fact that you
don't want to go to an auto parts store
because why would you what's so great
about an auto parts store you're just
going to stand in line
then you're going to get to the front of
the line then finally they're going to
tell you that they have to order the
part online and then
then they're going to upcharge you for
it instead here is something you could
do you could just
skip the middleman why not just go to
rockauto.com
it's much easier than walking into the
store and people demanding quick answers
and then ordering the part online
instead just go to rockauto.com and get
the part yourself rockauto.com always
offers the lowest prices possible rather
than changing prices based on what the
market will bear the way that airlines
do
why would you spend up to twice as much
for the same parts let's say
hypothetically
you happen to need like i don't know a
delphi fg 1456 fuel pump assembly for a
2005 to 2010 honda odyssey i know that
it popped into my head but it did
it cost like 354 bucks at a big chain
store
that's the kind of thing you could get
at rock auto for 217 bucks
rockauto.com is a family business
serving auto parts customers online for
20 years
head on over to rockauto.com to shop for
auto and body parts from hundreds of
manufacturers best of all
prices at rockauto.com are always
reliably low and the same for
professionals and
do-it-yourselfers so head on over to
rockauto.com right now they've got
amazing selection reliably low prices
all the parts your car will ever need
rockauto.com
head on over write shapiro in there how
did you hear about usbox so they know
that we sent you rockauto.com go check
them out okay so these two members of
congress have now issued
a series of letters to common carriers
telling them they want them to
essentially boot fox news off the air
and oann and newsmax and this is the
same sort of
top-down censorship that you are seeing
called for by our establishment media
against social media right let's force
social media not to disseminate
information
we don't like and there are a variety of
games they play
in order to shut down stuff they don't
like you'll notice one of the things
that they've done
and this is a pretty clever sleight of
hand
a lot of this debate really started
after the 2016 election in fact nearly
all of it before 2016
there's a basic acknowledgment that
there were alternative points of view
that were going to be presented online
there are alternative points of view
we're going to be presented on podcasts
and
talk radio and that was annoying to the
left
but they understood that you know you
sort of had to just deal with it
and then after 2016 there was this
moment where the left decided you know
what
we don't we shouldn't have lost that
election in fact we didn't lose that
election the only reason we lost that
election is because of russian
disinformation now disinformation you
know foreign intervention
using false information in order to
pervert the political process
is in fact not something that that the
government has to just leave alone
a foreign disinformation is something
the government can step into
it does have first amendment
consequences but there's some precedent
for the government stepping in and
stopping foreign actual interference
with disinformation
but you'll notice that there's a verbal
sleight of hand that went on
where the media and democratic members
of congress and democrats
in power they decided to shift from
russian disinformation to
misinformation now there's a difference
between disinformation and
misinformation
disinformation is active promotion of
false material by a foreign government
that's what disinformation typically is
right you do disinformation
on on the soviets or the soviets do
disinformation on you misinformation
is information that you perceive to be
mistaken
there's no obvious intent for somebody
to lie it's just something you perceive
to be mistaken and so what the left does
is they declare everything they don't
like misinformation
if there's a narrative they don't like
that's misinformation so they've now
shifted over
from fringe sort of issues when it comes
to speech
foreign disinformation the the russian
government promulgating falsehoods in
the middle of an election
to core political speech which they then
term misinformation
and then they set up a whole body of
fact checkers whose
sole design apparently is to label
anything they don't like
not only misinformation but mostly false
and this is what you see at politifact
politifact will label barack obama's
statement that if you like your doctor
you can keep your doctor half true for
several years and then only later will
they be like oh yeah that was the lie of
the year
it becomes misinformation when it is
convenient for them
and then they use those fake fact
checkers those pseudo fact checkers as
an excuse to shut down outlets they
don't like
on social media and to suppress their
reach
or they go to youtube and they say you
know what we know that there are a lot
of people out there who like
conservative material
but we are afraid that that conservative
material will lead to incitement
how well it's not even that those people
are doing anything that incites violence
it's not that jordan peterson does
anything that incites violence it's that
you might watch
jordan peterson video and then maybe
you'll get dragged into a rabbit hole of
right-wing extremism
okay so so they can they're consistently
broadening out
exceptions under american law that do
exist
to free speech and then they're letting
the exception eat the rule right so they
will say incitement is illegal it's true
incitement is illegal
then they will say that's stuff that
you're saying you know like normal
political stuff that's incitement
or they will say yeah we understand that
missing
that you know your narrative is is
opinion and it's protected
but it's really misinformation and
misinformation is really kind of like
disinformation and disinformation is
something that the government can fight
so really your speech is like russian
disinformation
okay this is the way that the left goes
about their top-down censorship
and it is tied into an ideology that
suggests
revolutionary aggression against the
system because the system of individual
rights is inherently discriminatory
according to the woke left the woke left
says
that individual rights are biased
because the people who are in a position
to best exercise their individual rights
are the powerful in our society
and those people must be brought to heal
so individual rights
take a back seat to what the collective
requires
individual rights take a backseat to
equity and this is the language that you
hear from the left
again these are the elements of
authoritarianism revolutionary
aggression
top down censorship and certainly the
most prevalent feeling on the left is
that if you disagree with them
it is because you are a moral lesser it
is because there is something wrong
with you it is because you believe in
brutality you're a phobe
right you're a racist sexist bigot
homophobe you're somebody you're a hater
okay the authoritarianism in the on the
left in the united states is
very very dominant at this point in
american life and it's becoming more
dominant every day
so here's this letter from these two
members of congress again directed at
taking down political opponents
here's the letter to john stanley stanky
rather
stanky is the ceo of at t dear mr stanky
again this comes from two sitting
members of congress our country's public
discourse is plagued by misinformation
disinformation conspiracy theories and
lies
look at that look at the conflation
there some of those things like russian
disinformation are things the government
has to say in
misinformation is not because you can
define that however you want
conspiracy theories depends on what you
think is a conspiracy theory right
and lies well i mean the left lied
throughout the summer that america's
police are systemically racist they
don't seem to care about that lie very
much
these phenomena undergird the
radicalization of seditious individuals
who committed active insurrection on
january 6th and it contributes to a
growing distrust of public health
measures
necessary to crush the pandemic right so
the idea here is that
we would have crushed the pandemic if it
were not for misinformation
disinformation conspiracy theories and
lies
uh weird because every single democratic
member of congress so far as i'm aware
backed mass protest in the middle of a
pandemic
because they said that racial issues
were a public health problem
in any case these members of congress
say we are concerned about the role atnc
plays in disseminating misinformation
misinformation again it's that that's
light of hand
misinformation to millions of its
u-verse directv and atn t tv subscribers
and we write to you today to request
additional information about what
actions att is taking to address these
issues now notice
congress does not have the power to
regulate at t
into shutting down free speech that'd be
a violation of the first amendment so
instead they will send nasty threatening
letters
to places like comcast and a t and they
will basically say
you know nice company you got there
would be a real shame if something
happened to it
real shame if something happened to a t
over there you know we you know we have
been looking into like these other you
know sort of anti-trust issues and
and i can tell you that if you weren't
doing this this fostering of
misinformation
well then maybe we would stop looking
into that i'm not threatening you or
anything of course
it's not a threat i mean this is the way
the game is played now
nearly half of americans get their news
primarily from tv say these two members
of congress
however not all tv news sources are the
same some purported news outlets have
long been misinformation rumor mills and
conspiracy theory hotbeds that produce
content that leads to real harm
now we get the incitement argument right
is if there's information
that you don't like or if there are even
things that are not true that are said
that you don't like
that those aren't necessarily incitement
that's not true lots of things are said
in american public discourse
every day and we have laws against
things like slander and libel so you can
sue people based on some of the things
some of those things we have incitement
statutes that are on the books
those incitement statutes require actual
incitement not just people saying things
that are false
you will also note that these democrats
have no problem with the
radical level of things that are not
true being said on places like cnn and
msnbc
for full on a year we heard that andrew
cuomo was the greatest governor on
planet earth
cnn reported that the kids from
covington catholic were vicious racists
covington the the mainstream
establishment media
pushed the idea that brett kavanaugh was
a rapist none of those things ended up
being true
denmark it's only one type of quote
unquote misinformation you'll know that
they're very upset about
misinformation on tv has led to our
current polluted
in information environment that
radicalizes individuals to commit
seditious acts
and rejects public health best practices
among other issues in our public
discourse
and so again the the idea is that if you
allow things i don't like then the
public discourse is polluted
okay well it may very well be polluted
seriously
i'll acknowledge that there's
information in the public discourse that
i think pollutes the public discourse
for example
if a member of the snl cast puts out the
overt lie
that the state of israel has been not
handing out vaccines to its arab
citizens
that seems like something that pollutes
the public discourse do i have any right
to call for snl to be canceled
on that basis should i call for for if i
remember of congress would i have the
ability constitutionally speaking to
regulate that of course not
there's a lot of stuff in the public
discourse that is chaff and then there
are some that is wheat and it is your
job to distinguish between the two
but the authoritarian left believes it
is their job to distinguish for you and
then use their power
to cram down in sensorious fashion
exactly what they like
so say these congress people experts
have noted that the right-wing media
ecosystem is quote-unquote much more
susceptible to disinformation
lies and half-truths well i mean if they
say so
that wow i mean amazing how they came to
that conclusion it's just the right-wing
media ecosystem that's susceptible to
disinformation lies
and half-truths doesn't matter that for
four long years
a vast bulk of democrats believed that
the 2016 election was stolen
right-wing media outlets like newsmax
one american news network and fox news
all aired misinformation about the
november 2020 elections for example
both newsmax and oann ran quote
incendiary reports of false information
following the elections
and continue to support an angry and
dangerous subculture that will continue
to operate
semi-openly as a violent mob was
breaching the doors of the capital
newsmax's coverage called the scene a
sort of romantic idea
fox news meanwhile has spent years
spewing misinformation about american
politics notice the conflation there
right
fox news is exactly the same as newsmax
it's exactly the same as
oann and i do love that that apparently
newsmax calling the scene a
quote-unquote sort of romantic idea
which is not
a good thing to say that that apparently
is the sort of offense that you'd get
newsmax taken off a t
however cnn which overtly promoted riots
in the middle of the summer
i mean chris cuomo went on television
and he said where does it say in the
constitution that protest is supposed to
be peaceful
and somehow that didn't promote right
it's only one side of the aisle you'll
note
these same networks say these congress
people have also been key vectors of
spreading misinformation related to the
pandemic
a media watchdog found over 250 cases of
coven 19 misinformation on fox news
in just one five-day period economists
demonstrated fox news had a demonstrable
impact
on non-compliance with public health
guidelines they actually didn't we
studied that at the time
the evidence that fox news was directly
responsible
for people not wearing masks for example
is exorbitantly weak they couldn't even
link
the people who are not wearing the mask
to people who are watching for example
sean hannity
one online platform suspended and
demonetized oann's channel online
because it was spreading
coveted 19 misinformation news max's
amplified allegations that members of
the chinese communist party helped
develop the coveted 19 vaccine that
really that's that's the big one that
you came up with newsmax
is that newsmax said that maybe the ccp
has something to do with the with the
development of the virus okay in reality
there was a there's a fairly
good amount of information that this
thing well not created by the ccp was in
fact
leaked from a wuhan lab there's more
information to that suggestion than
there is to the idea that it came from
the web markets as we were originally
told
and some idiot data bad but say these
members of congress
sadly these facts were not new one
popular television show aired a segment
about on last april that included a dire
warning the kind of misinformation oann
is spewing right now
could end up getting people killed oh
wow
you quoted last week tonight with john
oliver amazing
if john oliver says it must be true
because john oliver is a super reliable
source
we'll continue with the censorship that
the democrats are now pushing this is
authoritarian stuff
and it can come with a happy face but
the happy face does not make it
any sort of uh it does not mean that
these people are in favor of liberty
they absolutely are not we'll get to
more on this in just one second first
if you want to save time and you want to
save money there's a great way to do it
don't go to the post office
like the post office is great but let's
be real you can do all the things that
you do at the post office
cheaper and by spending less time at
stamps.com
i recommend mailing and shipping online
at stamps.com stamps.com will allow you
to mail and chip anytime anywhere
right from your computer you can send
letters ship packages and pay a lot less
with discounted rates from usps ups and
more here at daily wire we've
been using stamps.com since 2017. we're
not wasting our time
stamps.com brings the services of the us
postal service and ups directly
to your computer it's a must-have for
any business you use your computer
to print official us postage 24 7 for
any letter
any package any class mail anywhere you
want to send it once your mail is ready
you just schedule a pickup or you drop
it off it is indeed
that simple with stamps.com you get
discounts of up to 40 off post office
rates
and up to 62 off us ups shipping rates
not to mention stamps.com is a fraction
of the cost of those expensive
postage meters stamps.com is a
no-brainer it saves you time
it saves you money it's no wonder a
million small businesses already use
them so stop wasting your time go to
stamps.com no risk with my promo code
shapiro you get a special offer it
includes a four week trial plus free
postage and digital scale no long-term
commitments no contracts just head on
over to stamps.com click on that
microphone at the top of the homepage
type in shapiro that is stamps.com
promo code shapirostamps.com never go to
the post office again
alrighty so now we get to the crux of
the matter from these democratic
congress people so they've spent most
of this letter so far yelling about how
they don't like fox news and oann
and newsmax and how they're spewing
misinformation now i've talked about
some of the things i think
that oann and newsmax in particular were
pushing about the election that were not
true
that i saw no evidence for and in fact
onn has been forced to
back off some of its allegations with
regards to dominion same thing with
newsmax
okay all of that is true because there
are slander and libel laws in the united
states
both of them i believe are currently
being sued by dominion that is the
system working
i'll tell you what is not the system
working setting members of congress
looking to have platforms
d-platform things they don't like
that's dangerous stuff that's
authoritarian stuff that's top-down
censorship in full authoritarian leftist
mode
so here's what these congress people say
remember there's a letter to the head of
att
yet to our knowledge the cable satellite
and over-the-top companies that
disseminate these media outlets to
american viewers have done nothing in
response to the misinformation
aired by these outlets atnc currently
carries fox news newsmax and oann
on u-verse directv and at t tv as a
company that serves 17 million americans
atnc plays a major role in the spread of
dangerous misinformation that enabled
the insurrection of january 6th
and hinders our public health response
to the current pandemic in other words
in other words
if you don't mirror what we believe we
believe that you should shut them down
no notice what they're doing again
congress cannot pass a law restricting
freedom of speech
but members of congress can pressure
companies like at t
into restricting freedom of speech
they're essentially turning these
companies into their agents
in order to shut down free speech which
is authoritarian stuff
it really is it is government working
hand in glove with corporations to shut
down your freedom of speech corporations
know this by the way why do you think
that
coca-cola is doing diversity training
they're doing so for fear of liability
they're doing so because they're afraid
they're gonna be sued
and that you're gonna get some lefty
judge who decides that discrimination
has taken place
because they didn't insulate themselves
by buying a 20 000 robin deangelo
bullcrap course
the reason coca-cola is doing this is
that the democrats leave them alone
right the reason that all of these
corporations are caving to the woke mob
is because the woke mob has the levers
of power in a wide variety of
institutions right now
not just at the top of corporations
where there are a lot of people who had
corporations
who are sympathetic to the woke mob but
they have the whip hand when it comes to
the media they have the whip hand when
it comes to the social media companies
and most of all they have the whip hand
when it comes to members of congress who
are willing to shut down free speech
not formally through passage of a law
but through simple outside pressure
so say these congress people it is for
these reasons we ask you provide us with
responses to the following questions
about atnc's policies
to our content carried on u-verse
directv and a-t
what moral or ethical principles do you
apply in deciding which channels to
carry or want to take adverse actions
against a channel they're deliberately
these are not questions directed
eliciting answers of course these are
questions
listed at directed at eliciting a
response namely the cancellation
of all of these outlets that anna eshoo
and and jerry mcnerney don't like
two do you require through contracts or
otherwise that the channels you carry
abide by any content guidelines
if so please provide a copy of the
guidelines how many of your subscribers
tune in to fox news newsmax and oann on
u-verse directv and at t tv
for each of the four weeks preceding the
november 3rd 2020 elections
please specify the number of subscribers
that tuned in to each channel
and you know that is the predicate for
them setting up some sort of liability
argument as though att is liable
for damage done at the capitol building
because there were morons who decided to
commit criminal acts
on the basis of speech that may or
may not have been true but certainly did
not meet the standard of legal
incitement
what steps did you take prior to on or
following the november 3rd 2020
elections
to monitor respond to and reduce the
spread of disinformation
including encouragement or incitement of
violence by channels your company
disseminates to millions of americans
please describe each step that you took
have you taken any adverse actions
against a channel including fox news
for using your platform have you ever
taken actions against a channel for
using your platform to disseminate
disinformation are you planning to
continue carrying fox news newsmax and
oann
okay these are members of congress who
are overtly attempting
to shut down the dissemination of
information because they don't like
these channels
okay all of this led to federal
communications commissioner brendan carr
calling this effort a chilling
transgression of free speech he wrote a
letter to them he said by writing
letters to cable providers and other
regulated entities that carry these news
media outlets the democrats are
sending a message that is that is as
clear as it is troubling these regulated
entities will pay a price if the
targeted newsrooms do not conform to
democrats preferred political narratives
this is a chilling transgression of the
free speech rights that every media
outlet
in this country enjoys he says debate on
matters of public interest should be
robust uninhibited and wide open
more speech is better than less yet the
concerted effort by democrats you drive
political dissent from the public square
represents a market departure from these
first amendment norms a newsroom's
decision about what stories to cover and
how to frame them should be beyond the
reach of any government's official
not targeted by them he says to the
house democrats that use their official
letterhead to launch the same query i
would say this your demand to know the
quote-unquote moral principles that
guide a private entity's decision about
what news to carry
cannot be reconciled with bedrock
principles of free speech and
journalistic freedom i call on my fcc
colleagues to join me in publicly
denouncing this attempt to stifle
political speech and independent news
judgment
but here's the thing the biden
administration is happy with this sort
of stuff
the biden administration has never
sounded off in favor of free speech
principles
and but and this doesn't apply even
internally to media outlets on the left
media outlets on the left are happy to
fire people who cross them
and whether you're talking about the new
york times deciding get rid of don
mcneill
for the grave sin of using the n-word in
a conversation about why you shouldn't
use the n-word
or today the big story is that slate
decided that they were going to get rid
of a guy named mike pesca okay now slate
is a very left-wing outlet mike pesca
committed a-sin a graveson what did he
do
he used the n-word in describing why you
should not use the n-word
according to defector.com mike pesca
host of slate's daily podcast the gist
has been suspended from the company
indefinitely
sources confirmed that peska's
indefinite suspension is without pay and
that his access to the company's slack
and email channels had been revoked
the memo announcing pesca's suspension
sent by slate ceo dan check
refers obliquely to a conversation that
took place in slack last week
defector has obtained images of the
slack conversation that checks memo
refers to in which peska argues a point
has previously gotten to hot water for
arguing
that in some contexts white people
should be allowed to say the n-word
okay again this was in a discussion of
the don mcneill story from the new york
times
so pesca argued that mcniel's journalism
made the times more valuable to more
americans than having ousted him in 2019
would have he said my points are his
internal conduct was in a gray area
you guys don't think it was he said
expressing the views not the word
the views he did on that trip are not
fireable worthy of talking to
or what are you doing as a
representative of the times but nothing
requiring much angst among managements
or staff
or no should the times discipline
staffers who question the idea of white
supremacy or who express retrograde
ideas
on mass incarceration the question is is
an out loud utterance of that word in a
work environment fireable censurable etc
even as a point of clarification to a
question exactly about the use of that
word
and this led to him essentially being
fired
pesca made a final point i don't think
it's proper to use it in casual
conversation the n-word i'm in no
position to tell black new york times
workers they shouldn't be worried it's
going to pop out of a colleague's mouth
at some point
if you want my opinion it's that there
are some limited reasons why a
non-african-american journalist or
professor would use that word when
conveying a quote
in the name of clarity or factualness
but it's not a comfortable point to even
pursue right now if i had the opposite
opinion i know 100 ways i could make the
opinion i actually have seem horrible
and racist and you know what
maybe it is so that's when the boss
chimed in and said maybe we should stop
this conversation
and a slate staffer said quote said this
quote i feel outraged
i cannot believe i had to watch him
enthusiastically provoke people on
whether or not
it is appropriate to use a racist slur
other slave staffers that spoke to
defector expressed frustration and anger
at pesca's insistence on having that
particular conversation quote
i don't want to be in a workplace where
people feel emboldened to have this
argument
people's humanity is not an intellectual
debate
okay slate editor-in-chief jared holt
then posted a message and slack saying
he didn't ever want to see a similar
argument in slack ever
again ever again he said well we are a
workplace where people argue about
things all the time
it's also a workplace where we must
think very hard about the lived
experience of colleagues whose
experience
is different than ours pesc has been
suspended for a week
and then it has been suspended upgraded
to indefinite
this is insane this is insane and by the
way according to holt
he said that if pesca had actually used
the n-word he didn't even use the n-word
by the way in this conversation so
revision he didn't even use the n-word
he said there might be situations in
which using the n-word is not a fireable
offense because you are quoting somebody
for example holt said that if pesca had
used the n-word he definitely would have
been fired
this is insane okay and that staffer
shock apparently was not
because people were upset about about
what the bosses were doing
it's because pesca had actually said the
n-word at work
why he said the n-word at work because
he was quoting somebody
so then they they've suspended him or
fired him
from slate okay this is the
authoritarian left at work
and they have the upper hand in major
corporations
on the left not just in on the left in
major corporations across the board
so for example ryan anderson an
excellent thinker over at the heritage
foundation he writes on trans issues
is in a really really good book we've
talked about it on the show it's called
when harry became sally responding to
the transgender movement
and it is a logical point by point
debunking many of the myths surrounding
transgenderism
and gender identity and the idea that
gender is entirely malleable he goes
through all the science
amazon pulled his book this week so it's
a
there's the best description of that
would be a digital book burning when you
actually remove a book
from amazon that is a digital book
burning because the goal of a book
burning is to remove
that book from circulation they just
removed it that comes on the heels just
a few months ago the attempt by amazon's
removed abigail schreier's book
from their shelves so now they're doing
it to ryan ryan anderson's when harry
became sally
encounter books which is the publisher
they said if amazon which controls most
of the book sales in america
has decided to de-list a book with which
some of its functionaries disagree
this is an unconscionable assault on
free speech it will have a chilling
effect on the publishing industry and
the free circulation of ideas
it must not be left to stand
unchallenged that is 100 right but again
the authoritarian left is on the march
the authoritarian left has cudgeled
corporations into doing the censorious
work government cannot do
they've gotten corporations to mirror
their authoritarian priorities
we already know that the media mirror
their authoritarian priorities they
cheer this stuff on day after day
we know that social media has begun
mirroring those authoritarian priorities
because they're being pushed into it by
the way it differs by corporation
twitter is enthusiastic to do it
facebook i think reluctantly does it but
the reality is that when you have
congress sitting on your neck
and saying they're going to break you up
unless you do their bidding what you end
up with i mean dianne feinstein
literally said that
she literally said to the heads of
social media if you don't police this
content
we are going to have to do something
about it ourselves okay that is a
violation
of first amendment principles but the
authoritarian left is in control so
when people say that there is an
authoritarian right and that is a grave
threat to the country
there is a fringe authoritarian right
i'm not going to pretend that there
aren't people
on the right who believe in
authoritarian principles and who don't
like democracy very much or who think
that democracy is so improperly
functioning that we need to overthrow it
or stuff like that
there are some people who believe that
that is a small number of people
the mainstream democratic party
apparently believes that it is okay to
use
the positions of power they have at
american corporations and american
institutions at universities in the
media and in government
in order to cram down an anti-first
amendment anti-free speech anti-liberty
position
that is a mainstream left position the
authoritarian left went to war with the
liberals and the authoritarian left
apparently won
that is where things currently stand
alrighty in just a second
we're going to be getting to joe biden
who uh apparently is a good president
according to the press because
he is very empathetic that's all that
matters that he's empathetic doesn't
matter that he's pushing policy that
makes no sense he's empathetic because
that's all we care about these days
we'll get some more of that in just one
second first
if you are looking to make your company
stronger you need the best employees
obviously
and the best way to get great employees
is to head on over to ziprecruiter.com
dailywire ziprecruiter does all the work
for you when you post a job on zip
recruiter it gets sent out to over 100
top job sites with one click
then zip recruiters matching technology
finds people with the right skills and
experience for your job and actively
invites them to apply
you get qualified candidates fast so
while other services may overwhelm you
with applications to sift through
zip recruiter finds you what you are
looking for the needle in the haystack
in fact
ziprecruiter is so effective that four
out of five employers who post on
ziprecruiter get a quality candidate
through the site within
the very first day right now you can try
zip recruiter for free at
ziprecruiter.com
dailywire that's ziprecruiter.com
d-a-i-l-y-w-i-r-e just go to
ziprecruiter.com
daily why are we here at the dailywear
are constantly seeking to upgrade
our staff that is why we use zip
recruiter on essentially a daily basis
we are constantly adding jobs if you
want to work here you should check out
zip recruiter by the way if you want to
work in any great company you should
check out zip recruiter because all the
best companies are using it
if your company isn't you're missing out
check out ziprecruiter.com
dailywire that is ziprecruiter the
smartest way to hire already we're going
to get to
the joe biden commemoration for 500 000
lives lost first
it's that time of month when i get to
sit down with some of my favorite
people in the world for an episode of
backstage
yeah you can tell i'm enthused but watch
me suffer
as i join jeremy boring matt walsh
andrew clavin and yes the excarable
and unthinkably awful michael knowles
tomorrow night 7 pm eastern as we
roundtable about current events and big
picture issues
like oh probably cancel culture so join
us at dailywire.com or
on the daily wire youtube to watch again
that is 7 p.m eastern 6 p.m central
before
going any further i want to tell you all
about a new show coming out this friday
hosted by moana i told you at the
beginning of the year we had all sorts
of excellent content that was coming to
daily wire
right you know that later on this year
we're going to have on candace owns
ken's going to have a new show here at
daily wire
you already know that we're making a
movie with gina karana we already
brought out run hide fight we have all
sorts of amazing content for you now i
am bringing out a new series and this
series is going to be so
useful for you it's going to be
incredibly useful for you what is it
basically i just debunk a leftist myth
every week the left
is constantly making arguments that are
filled with fallacies and
anti-factual assertions every friday in
15 minutes or less
exclusively for our daily wire members i
have a new show it's called debunked
every week i'll take a fact and logic
position and put it up against a popular
leftist argument the kind you see your
friends post and share all over the
internet whether it's climate change or
universal healthcare i'm going to help
you completely dismantle
those particular arguments so if you're
not already a daily wire member head on
over to dailywire.com
subscribe use the code debunked to get
off the first episode drops this friday
so head on over to dailywire.com
subscribe today it's a great resource
for you only available to our members
use code debunked for 25
off you're listening to the largest
fastest growing conservative podcast and
radio show in the nation
alrighty meanwhile joe biden did a
commemorative event
for five hundred thousand american lives
lost to cover nineteen obviously that is
a massive
tragedy every one of those lives lost is
indeed a tragedy
and the the goal here was really twofold
one was
for him to demonstrate empathy as you
will see this is the the
biden line right this is the line all
throughout the campaign is that donald
trump had no empathy but joe biden is a
man of empathy and this is what the
media like about him
is that he is capable of emoting i mean
that that is his
right it's his thing i'm not saying it's
not genuine sure
i'll give him that i'm sure that a lot
of his his emotion is genuine
that's fine emotion doesn't happen to
solve problems very often emotion gets
in the way of solving problems and
i don't judge presidents on how much
empathy they have i judge presidents on
how well they do in doing the things
they are supposed to do
i don't care whether my plumber has
empathy i don't care whether my lawyer
has empathy and i don't care whether the
president has empathy
i am very i've been clear about this
since the get-go in fact there are good
studies to show
that sympathy is useful in politics
because it allows you to think about a
wide variety of people who are not you
but empathy is actually a problem
empathy is where you put yourself in
somebody else's shoes
sympathy is where you sympathize with
somebody else's positions empathy
makes you elevate certain people above
other people because you are empathizing
with them right so empathy can actually
be a problem in politics there's a great
book called against empathy
by uh by a psychologist all about this
about how it infuse how in politics it's
kind of a problem
in any case joe biden does this
event and in the middle of the event he
basically is the goal of the event is
not only to to demonstrate empathy but
then
to suggest that people who disagree with
his agenda
that the people who don't agree with the
way he's approaching policy are not
empathetic
right that is what politics usually is
is trying to create
a level of moral superiority for
yourself and make your opponents
seem morally inferior so joe biden does
this event and he says for example it's
time to end the politics and the
misinformation
okay as we've been talking about for
weeks at this point joe biden has been a
chief purveyor of coveted misinformation
since his uh accession to the office of
president
he has put out the idea that there was
no covert plan a lie he suggested that
the covet vaccine plan did not exist a
lie
he has had people promoting the idea
that teachers cannot go back to school
safely right now
a lie the president of the united states
has been
overtly using teachers union talking
points and just shoving them into cdc
standards
okay which is disinformation and
misinformation as the left likes to say
okay but here is joe biden nonetheless
saying that his opponents are the ones
who are promoting
politics and misinformation he's the
president he doesn't get to do this
routine anymore
now is the time for you to actually do
your job we must end the politics and
misinformations divided families
communities in the country it's cost too
many lives already
it's not democrats and republicans who
are dying from the virus
it's our fellow americans it's our
neighbors our friends
our mothers our fathers our sons our
daughters
husbands wives
we have to fight this together as one
people
as the united states of america okay
that that is such a string of platitudes
what does that mean
what does that mean can we get specific
here
if if people are saying that you should
go out and you should congregate with
other people and there's no risk of
covet if you
without vaccination or anything and they
should not wear a mask and not socially
a distance
yeah that's going to spread the virus
okay so if you say that then that would
be and and you say it's not going to
spread the virus that's misinformation
but if we are talking generally
as joe biden says that that
misinformation is the cause of the virus
spreading
uh i noticed something which is that
andrew cuomo your favorite government
litera
governor literally lied to the american
people to his own constituents to the
families of people who died he lied to
his fellow democratic legislators and
your administration won't even say that
and then you have the temerity to get up
at one of these events and say something
like
we have to stop the misinformation in
the politics i don't believe you
i don't believe that you are interested
in that president biden i wish that i
believed you
but i don't but again the goal here is
just to get the media to to
cry over him which he uh which he did
successfully here was cnn's john king
saying you know he's empathetic that's
really the thing that matters is the
empathy the empathy the empathy you know
what i notice is actually more important
than the empathy reopening the schools
and getting people the vaccines they
need
and also not telling people that the
vaccine is not going to allow us to get
back to regular life
you want to talk about putting out
misinformation how about the idea that
we that we believe that you're going to
transmit the virus
at the same rates whether or not you get
the vaccine okay that suggestion has
been put out there
it is absolutely evidence-free that's
misinformation
the vaccine does lower not only your
risk of death to something like 99
your risk of death goes down your risk
of serious illness goes down by like 95
but also your risk of transmission goes
down by something like 90
according to the latest studies it's
misinformation to suggest otherwise
but we don't care about that all we care
about is that joe biden is a caring
person he cares about you
okay here's the thing let me just tell
you a little secret
joe biden may be a caring person the
government doesn't care about you
because the government doesn't know your
name
you're a taxpayer that's all the
government care that's all the
government cares about
you're just a you are just a tool for
them you're a widget to the government
now phil gramm the former senator from
texas he uh he was once
told in a hearing by by some witness
that that that witness cared about his
children and phil gramm said really what
are their names
that is that is exactly how you should
respond when someone from the government
says i care about you your first
response should be
no you you really don't you care about
me in the same way that a plumber cares
about me paying him to fix my toilet
why should we pretend that our
politicians are the most caring and
wonderful of people when we all know
that this is precisely the opposite
but again you have to promulgate the
notion that joe biden is full of empathy
so that you don't
catch on to the fact that he's actually
foolish here's here's
here's john king from cnn you have a
president
who is shaped joe biden whether you're a
democrat or republican or independent
out there watching he's been shaped by
the personal tragedy in his own life he
understands what it is like
for a family to suffer for a family to
lose and for a family to have to get up
and recover and that's why this is his
mo and his dna wolf to be an empathetic
president
and to not try to hide from these
numbers uh he inherited a mess in the
trump administration but he is now
accountable
in what ways you've been held
accountable by you in the media
seriously have you seen one headline
holding joe biden accountable for the
hundred thousand americans who have died
since he took office
and every every day there was a headline
like it's unthinkable how many americans
it's 83 vietnam wars that have happened
under donald trump
a hundred thousand americans have died
since joe biden took office i haven't
seen one of those headlines not one
but you know he's empathetic that's all
that matters dana bash did the same
thing on cnn you know trump was a very
non-empathetic character but we know
that joe biden is empathetic he's all
empathy all the time
what an event that uh the white house
put on
for the american people and for the
world to memorialize the half a million
people
who have been taken by this virus and
you know i don't want to do a lot of
looking back but at
almost the same location where his
predecessor
came back from the hospital having the
virus himself and ripped off his mask
what a difference just a few months
makes and having somebody who
as my colleagues have said uh you know
wants to emote and to empathize and to
sympathize
and to grieve with this country okay i'm
not looking for a psychologist i'm not
looking for a priest
i'm not looking for a rabbi i'm looking
for a guy who's actually going to do
what he promised and crush the fighters
he's not doing any of that stuff
in fact he's enthralled to a bunch of
people whose policies are completely
non-empathetic
because they don't actually care about
americans let me give you an example ro
hannah is a democratic congress person
and he says he was asked about minimum
wage right the minimum wage is in the
joe biden covered relief bill
here's his response about minimum wage
killing small businesses does this sound
empathetic to you because when it comes
to the policy this crap ain't empathetic
here is ro how does this in your view
affect
mom and pop businesses who are just
struggling to keep their doors open keep
workers on the payroll right now
well they shouldn't be doing it by
paying people low wages we don't want
uh low-wage businesses i think most
successful small businesses can pay
a fair wage so i love small businesses
i'm all for it but i don't want small
businesses that are
underpaying employees it's fair for
people to be making
what they're producing and i think 15 is
very reasonable in this sounds
empathetic
he knows how your business runs better
than you do and if you don't agree with
him he's perfectly happy for your
business to go under
that's all that matters to him right
sounds empathetic to you doesn't it
super empathy empathy he's empathetic
he's empathetic also if your business
goes under it he doesn't care
also if your kid can't go back to school
he didn't care you want to know what the
actual
underlying emotivism here is about it is
all about
garnering sympathy for political
positions that are completely
non-empathetic
we all know this the biden
administration is mirroring all of the
priorities
of the american federation of teachers
when it comes to reopening schools
here by the way is what the american
federation of teachers president randy
weingarten had to say
about whether kids are going to recover
from missing an entire year of school
not being with their classmates
experiencing significant
mental health disorders really i know
many people who have had
kids who are suffering with this sort of
stuff here is the very empathetic randy
weingarten on this topic
i believe that kids are resilient oh and
kids will recover
oh but we as adults have to meet their
needs
their emotional needs their social needs
their learning needs
and that's who america's educators are
but at the end of the day
we have to believe that this is
recoverable
and we have to believe that virtually
all
our kids will thrive with the
opportunities
that we put before them okay so what she
just said is f the kids okay let me
translate that very quickly she said
after kids that's what that meant
okay so for all of the empathy and the
emotivism what it really comes down to
when it comes down to policy is which
constituency can i please today
recognize this is true for all of your
politicians democrat
republican all of them anybody who looks
for you you want sympathy get a dog
you want you want empathy get married
you want to
you want your politicians to bring you
these things you're looking for love in
all the wrong places and you deserve to
have
whatever ridiculous policy they promote
shove down your face
because if that's where if that's where
you're looking for your love my goodness
get a life get a community get friends
all right we'll be back here later today
with an additional hour of content
otherwise coming up soon is the matt
wall show that airs at 1 30 pm eastern
be sure to check that out over at
dailywire.com i'm ben shapiro this is
the ben shapiro show
the ben shapiro show is produced by
colton haas executive producer jeremy
boring
our supervising producers are mathis
glover and robert sterling production
manager pavel wydowsky
our associate producers are rebecca
doyle and savannah dominguez the show is
edited by adam's psy events
audio is mixed by mike coromina hair and
makeup is by fabiola christina
production assistant jessica crand the
ben shapiro show is a daily wire
production copyright 2021
on the matt well show we talk about the
things that matter real issues that
affect you your family our country not
just politics but culture
faith current events all the
fundamentals if they matter to you come
check out the show